joe biden declares the election over and
the media demand republicans repeat that
republicans claim voter fraud and
irregularity while attorney general
william barr authorizes investigations
and pfizer develops a miraculous vaccine
possibility for covid i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
protected at expressvpn.com
we'll get to everything in the news in
just one moment first let us talk about
the fact
that everybody wishes that black friday
and cyber monday that these were
everyday things because you could save
lots of money but here is an easy way
for you to save lots of money without
changing anything that matters to you in
terms of quality i'm talking about your
cell phone coverage so
you got coverage from verizon or at t or
t-mobile what if you could get that
exact same coverage but
save a bundle on that coverage well this
is where pure talk usa
comes in pure talk can easily save you
over 400 bucks a year listen this is all
you need unlimited talk text two gigs of
data for just 20 bucks a month
if you go over on data usage they don't
charge you for it one of the ways that
the cell phone providers get you is they
charge you for unlimited data that
you're not using because it is literally
impossible to use
unlimited data pure talk usa is not
going to overcharge you for the data
switching to pure talk is the easiest
decision you will make today you can
keep your phone and your number or get
great deals on the latest iphones and
android grab your mobile phone dial
pound 250 say ben shapiro when you do
you save 50 off your first month dial
pound 250 say keyword ben shapiro
puretalk is simply smarter wireless go
check them out right now and save a
fortune on your cell phone bill check
them out pure talk usa dial pound 250
and say
ben shapiro and when you do you save 50
off your first month
okay so the media have declared that the
election
is over and as i have kept saying i've
been saying this consistently i've said
it since
tuesday night the election is over when
the election is over the election is
technically not over
until all of the legal lawsuits come to
an end
until the election results are certified
until the electors are selected and then
actually vote
the election is not technically over and
while everyone seems to be panicking
like really like sheer panic in the
media over the fact that trump has not
conceded the election
who cares i mean really like who cares i
understand
that there are lots of people who are
very upset that trump hasn't conceded
the election and think it's undermining
the integrity
of our elections and that more americans
are not going to believe in the
integrity of our elections
okay let me just tell you it's a
temporary phenomenon okay
the reality of the situation is that
americans typically don't tend to
believe in elections
when the elections don't go their way
and this holds true for literally every
election
okay it's certainly been true since
2016.
so there are a lot of people today who
are pointing to gallup polling results
showing
that when it asked about election
integrity election integrity for
democrats
their belief in election integrity began
to soar as soon as they thought they'd
won the election
they're not talking so much about that
right but if you go back
all the way to say october 21st
on october 21st only a bare majority of
democrats said that the election
of 2020 was going to be free and fair
and you're not seeing the media talk
about that today
because that would undercut their
narrative which is that only republicans
doubt elections and the reason they
doubt elections is because of trump the
fact is the media we're saying for
months that we were going to get serious
voter suppression that trump was moving
mailboxes that the mail service was
going to somehow
disenfranchise hundreds of thousands of
people and so if you look back at the
polling data
by polling data democrats on october
21st only 51 percent said they thought
that the election was going to be free
and fair that same date
only 53 of republicans thought the
elections were going to be free and fair
and more than either independents
thought the elections were not going to
be free and fair
only 45 percent of independence thought
the election was going to be free and
fair
in fact on october 15th just a week
before that only 40
of independents thought the elections
were going to be free and fair okay so
there's a lot of fluctuation
in these numbers now after the election
when democrats think that they won the
national election when they think that
joe biden was elected
90 of democrats now say that they
believe that the elections are free and
fair
so that is a jump of 40 percent okay so
the media today
are all up on republican how dare you
guys undermine the integrity of our
elections i mean
back in october 25th 57 of republicans
said that they thought the elections
were free and fair today
only 26 of republicans say they believe
the elections are free and fair
okay well back on october 25th only 55
of democrats said they thought the
elections were free and fair fewer than
republicans
and now 90 of democrats think the
elections are free and fair so can we
just
point out that these stats on whether
people think elections are free and fair
are innately tied to who they think wins
the election
if you think your guy lost you think he
got cheated and if you think that your
guy won
you think the election system was
perfect chefs kiss excellent
right and this has been true for quite a
long time so i'm seeing a lot of people
talking about the dangers of the process
dragging on and the legal process
it's not dangerous it isn't and once we
get to january 20th somebody's going to
get inaugurated
in december the elector's going to meet
they're going to vote the fact that the
process is taking like we are so
impatient in our society
that this thing wasn't called tuesday
night or wednesday morning and everybody
started running around with their hair
on fire
and now it's the next week and guess
what joe biden is being prepped in case
he is the president's elect
and donald trump is still occupying the
oval office there's not going to be a
big battle trump is not going to lock
the doors and start sn snorting coke and
firing guns through the door
if in fact he is deemed to be the loser
of the election by the legal process
and just because cnn or msnbc or fox
news declares something there's no
constitutional provision that says
that this now ends the election and the
election is over and if you don't repeat
it this means you're a very bad terrible
no good very bad person
the reality is that if you look at this
thing in the bare light of day joe biden
looks more likely to be the president of
the united states when all this is said
and done come january 20th and the
reason for that is because currently he
has a 12 000 vote lead
in georgia a 15 000 vote lead in arizona
a 36 000 vote lead in nevada and a 45
000 vote lead in pennsylvania
in order for donald trump to win the
election he would need to overturn the
results in georgia arizona and
pennsylvania or get those states booted
out of court that is highly unlikely to
happen
okay so if you had to lay money on this
thing you'd lay heavy money on joe biden
being inaugurated in january but that
does not mean that the process is over
nor does it mean
that if the trump campaign shows
significant evidence of voter fraud like
really really significant like in the
tens of thousands to hundreds of
thousands of votes
that wouldn't shift the election is that
sort of a hope and a prayer for a lot of
republicans
sure is it also true that they're going
to definitely
be able to find evidence of voter fraud
and voter regularity absolutely
right they are absolutely going to be
able to find evidence of that because in
an election that involves 150 million
people voting you would assume
that there are going to be some people
who engage in voter fraud and voter
irregularity
and that is a very large number 150
million people but it's a very hard
stone to lift to suggest that hundreds
of thousands of votes were shifted
by voter fraud or to prove that in court
so people might be suspicious after the
election
hell after the election in 2016 67 of
democrats
literally 67 of democrats by polling
data said that the russians had switched
the vote numbers
so spare me all the hysterics about
people think the elections are rigged
and it's going to
completely destroy our democracy same
poll
today from from morning consult that's
showing that only 26 percent of
republicans say the elections were free
and fair
share that in 2016 only 39 of democrats
thought the elections were free and fair
today it's 90 is that because they're
super consistent
about american elections being free and
fair or is it because people tend to
follow their partisan no's
the last time that there was no partisan
gap in terms of
election process and people thinking the
election was fair was 2004.
in that election 65 percent of
independence 68 of democrats and 66
percent
of republicans thought that the election
was free and fair
but even if you go all the way back to
2000 only 44 of democrats thought that
the election
was free and fair in in other words in
every election
where your candidate loses you tend to
think that the process was skewed and in
every election where your candidate wins
you tend to think that the process was
not skewed
so let's take with a grain of salt all
of the talk about the end of democracy
because this this process is taking a
while because trump won't concede and be
great first of all
do you really believe that if trump said
tomorrow you're right i lost you you
think if he said that
that all of a sudden republicans would
be like sanguine about this thing that
they wouldn't suspect voter fraud or
voter irregularity
hillary clinton within the week of the
election conceded the election
and still a vast majority of democrats
thought russians had changed the votes
for four years we got to talk about how
trump was an illegitimate president
and the election was fixed on behalf of
vladimir putin and facebook or some such
nonsense
okay so again take everything the media
is telling you the grain of salt it is
the formation of a narrative
whereby anybody who wants to wait to
declare the election over
is a cat's paw of donald trump and is
complicit in the rejection of the
republic
there is a constitutional process the
constitutional process has not been
violated as of yet
it has not there is nothing in the
constitutional process that says that
donald trump has to concede before he
gets to go through his legal challenges
so the media are trying to build up
momentum for this idea and this is what
they constantly do
they they find a a statement that nobody
really made
and then they asked every republican to
defend the statement that nobody really
made
the media our big story in all of this
the constant driver by the media
is is a false narrative that
portrays one side as eminently
reasonable and the utter the other side
is eminently unreasonable
again after years of declaring stacey
abrams is still the governor of georgia
spare me the hysterics about people who
are wondering whether voter fraud and
voter irregularity impacted this
election
at least voter fraud and voter
irregularity you're going to have to
prove it
voter suppression there's no way to
prove voter suppression is an unprovable
thesis
and this is what stacey abrams alleged
she alleged that people not voting
was in fact the problem in georgia
because there's no way to un
unring that bell because the people who
voted voted and the people who didn't
didn't
and there's literally no way to prove
that people who didn't vote
didn't vote because they were suppressed
or because they just didn't want to or
for any other reason
voter suppression is a far harder charge
to prove than voter fraud the good news
is at the end of this process
either large amounts of voter fraud and
voter irregularity will have improved or
they will not have been proved
so all of the kind of crazy insane
hysterical conjecture about how the
american republic is on the brink and
everything's going to end because
republicans are following trump down the
primrose
we've been hearing this crap for years
it ain't going to happen everything's
fine yeah i know everything is fine it's
not what people want to hear right now
but it is we have a process for this and
the process is going to play out so calm
your asses down
we're gonna get some more of this in
just one second first let us talk about
the fact
that not too long ago over 100 million
people had their personal information
stolen
in a major data breach social security
numbers contact details credit scores
and more all taken from capital one
customers it's not just capital one
equifax ebay uber playstation and yahoo
have all leaked passwords
credit card info and bank numbers
belonging to billions of users
if you think hackers only target large
companies to get your information you
are
wrong that is why i use expressvpn to
safeguard my personal data online
according to recent reports hackers can
make up to a thousand bucks from selling
someone's personal information on the
dark web
making people like you and me easy
lucrative targets expressvpn is an app
for your computer and phone that secures
and encrypts your data so you can have
peace of mind
every time you go online the app
connects with just one click it's
lightning fast
the best part is expressvpn costs less
than seven bucks a month that is a great
way of protecting your data
if a breach can happen at capital one it
can certainly happen to you protect
yourself with expressvpn use my special
link expressvpn.com right now
arm yourself with an extra three months
of expressvpn for free that's
expressvpn.com for an extra three months
for free there's a reason i use
expressvpn to protect myself i'm always
worried about people stealing my data
you should be too and you should be
using expressvpn to protect yourself
today expressvpn.com
ben for an extra three months of
expressvpn for free
okay so joe biden has declared the
election over the media have declared
the election over and of course you're
very very bad if you don't also declare
the election over even if you say the
election has a natural terminus
it has a legal terminus we're going to
go through the process nope you're bad
here's joe biden saying the election is
over so stop talking about the election
the election's over
this election is over it's time to put
aside the pardons
the partisanship and the rhetoric that
designed to demonize one another it's
time to end the politicization
of basic responsible public health steps
like mask wearing
and social distancing we have to come
together to heal the soul of this
country so that we can effectively
address this crisis
as one country where hard-working
americans have each other's backs
okay so the election's over give it up
then we get whoopi goldberg the specter
of look b
goldberg saying that we have to suck it
up you know we sucked it up when trump
won in what way
did democrats suck it up when trump won
we got four long years of you whining
that trump wasn't the actual president
of the united states
not hashtag not my president the women's
march in the immediate aftermath of
trump
winning we we got huge black lives
matter protests throughout the summer
the idea being that
trump was the the fond head of systemic
american racism we got the media
and their collusion narrative that went
on for years on end despite lack of
evidence
we got an impeachment at what point did
democrats actually come to the terms of
the fact that trump had won they never
came to terms
which is why they're so celebratory now
because they think that now reality has
snapped back into place
but spare me like really all this stuff
is just
all these people who are unwilling to
accept the results of election now going
you know you guys you got to grow up i'm
not i'm not willing to hear that from
you i'm sorry whoppy goldberg i'm i
i think you have um i think you
literally have no leg to stand on here
this is well not literally i assume you
have legs but you have no leg to stand
on here here's whoopi goldberg when
you know who was elected four years ago
you know hillary clinton didn't say hey
wait a minute this doesn't feel right
stop the count she didn't say this isn't
right i'm not going for she didn't say
any of that
so all of you suck it up suck it up like
we sucked it up
and if you are not sure that you're
comfortable with joe biden
do what we did find things and then take
it to the law and if the law says it's
something to look at
look at it but from now on suck it up
okay that is literally what is happening
right now people are literally going to
the courts
they're literally filing affidavits and
so in the meantime
attorney general william barr he has put
out a memo to assistant u.s attorneys
all over the united states
telling them that if they see credible
evidence of election fraud then they
should investigate it this is being
taken by the media
as a sign that william barr has
militarized on behalf of the trump
campaign
literally he changed no legal standard
okay so the headlines are
william barr initiates investigations
and the meteor like yeah but we don't
see any evidence of serious widespread
voter fraud that's not what the letter
says so here's what william barr's
letter actually says he's the attorney
general here's what he actually says and
by the way
people are saying that this is him you
know basically trying to please
donald trump that this whole thing is
about him trying to appease donald trump
because donald trump doesn't want to
accept that he lost the election or
something
what if the reason that william barr is
doing this i mean here's a possible take
what if the reason william barr is doing
this is because number one there may
actually be credible allegations of
voter fraud out there that are worth
investigating and two
if there are not it is good for the doj
to be on record saying that they were
investigating those things so people
feel more safe and secure after the
election is over
did it ever occur to anybody that the
reason this process exists is so that
when the election is over
people at least are able to point to the
court cases and to the investigations
and say they
they came up empty right it turns out
the mueller investigation
it was bad and was badly predicated but
the mueller investigation did justify
trump's claims that there was no
collusion
made it very difficult for democrats to
claim there was collusion well after
this election
let's say that the doj comes up with no
serious allegations of widespread voter
fraud
it's gonna be a lot easier for people to
point to that and say okay there was no
widespread voter fraud that decided the
election
the purpose of the process is not to
come to a preset end
the purpose of the process is to ensure
the integrity of the elections
here was attorney general william
barth's letter he said last week our
nation once again demonstrated the
strength of our democracy as more than
140 million americans cast ballots to
select their leaders i want to thank
each of you
and your teams for your extraordinary
efforts to ensure that all americans
could exercise this most fundamental of
rights with confidence and in safety
now that the voting has concluded it is
imperative that the american people can
trust that our elections were conducted
in such a way that the outcomes
accurately reflect the will of the
voters although the states have the
primary responsibility to conduct and
supervise elections under our
constitution
and the laws enacted by congress the
united states department of justice has
an obligation to ensure that federal
elections are conducted
in such a way that the american people
can have full confidence in their
electoral process and their government
the department's general policies with
regard to election fraud investigations
are contained in the justice manual
these policies require among other
things consultation with the public
integrity section's election crimes
branch in some instances
those policies already allow preliminary
inquiries including witness interviews
to be conducted without ecb consultation
in instances in which they are consulted
the ecb's general practice has been to
council that overt investigative steps
ordinarily should not be taken until the
election in question has been concluded
its results certified in all recount and
election contests concluded
such a passive and delayed enforcement
approach can result in situations
in which election misconduct cannot
realistically be rectified
okay so in other words the process
usually is that you don't open an
investigation or announce an open
investigation
until after the election results are
certified because the crime hasn't
actually been finalized
at that point what bar is saying is
here's the problem we have an ongoing
presidential election
there's a date certain at which the
electors will vote on who the
president-elect of the united states is
and we need to know before then exactly
what the outcome of these investigations
is going to be whether they are serious
or whether they are unserious and so we
are expediting the process is that
really bad that we're expediting the
process
or would it be worse if let's assume for
a second that the doj actually came up
with evidence of widespread voter fraud
wouldn't it be significantly worse if
the electors went and voted joe biden
into office
and then two years from now the doj came
to the conclusion that hundreds of
thousands of votes did shift right
wouldn't that be a lot worse
so he's saying expedite the process so
that we can actually make sure that the
right person
is is elected to the president's elect
of the united states
he says the ccb practice has never been
a hard and fast rule case-specific
determinations and judgments must be
made while most allegations of purported
election misconduct are of such a scale
they would not impact the outcome of an
election and thus
investigation can be appropriately be
deferred that is not always the case
furthermore any concerns that overt
actions taken by the department could
inadvertently impact an election are
greatly minimized if they exist at all
once voting has concluded even if
election certification has not yet been
completed
in other words the idea that the doj is
now shifting votes there's no election
to be had the votes are already in
given this and given that voting in our
current elections has now concluded i
authorize you to pursue substantial
allegations of voting and vote
tabulation irregularities
prior to the certification of elections
in your jurisdictions in certain cases
as i have already done in specific
instances okay now this
this line has been taken out of context
to suggest that barr
is overtly saying there has in fact been
substantial allegations of voting and
vote tabulation irregularities
that is not what he is saying he's
saying if you identify such substantial
allegations
you should investigate them he is not
averring that those
vote tabulation and vote irregularities
have been widespread he is saying if you
find
any evidence or allegations that such
voting fraud has been widespread or
regularity's been widespread go ahead
and investigate the media
went nuts on this went nuts on this how
dare he he says
any investigation of claims of
irregularities that if true would
clearly not impact the outcome of a
federal election in an individual state
should normally be deferred until after
the election certification process is
completed
while u.s attorneys maintain their
inherent authority to conduct inquiries
and investigations as they deem
appropriate
it will likely be prudent to commence
any election-related matters as a
preliminary inquiry so as to assess
whether available evidence warrants
further investigative steps
he says it is equally imperative that
department personnel exercise
appropriate caution
and maintain the department's absolute
commitment to fairness neutrality and
nonpartisanship you're the most senior
leaders in the us department of justice
i trust you to exercise great care and
judgment in addressing allegations of
voting
and vote tabulation irregularities while
serious allegations should be handled
with great care
specious speculative fanciful or
far-fetched claims should not be a basis
for initiating federal inquiries
nothing here should be taken as any
indication that the department has
concluded that voting irregularities
have impacted the outcome of any
election
rather i provide this authority and
guidance to emphasize the need to timely
and appropriately address allegations
of voting irregularities so that all of
the american people regardless of their
preferred candidate or party can have
full confidence in the results
of our elections okay should this be
wildly controversial uh no
it should not what william barr is doing
here is not wildly controversial
nothing major is changing he's simply
saying that instead of deferring the
election investigation until after all
of the votes
have been certified i'm now giving you
the authority to go and investigate
serious allegations of voter fraud if
they arise
that seems perfectly appropriate to me
the the idea that william barr is now
you know playing offense for donald
trump here no
no he's doing what the doj ought to be
doing which is investigating serious
allegations of voter fraud before
the possibility of the rectification of
the problem can and disappears
because it does disappear on a
particular date okay so in a second
we're going to get to some of the
allegations
that have been leveraged levied by the
trump campaign
we'll get to that and we'll get to the
difficulty of the process because the
realistic
outcome here is that the election
results as currently stated probably do
not change the reason being
again the amount of voter fraud and
voter irregularity is not in the
hundreds of thousands even if it were it
would be incredibly difficult to prove
that
and i think that it is important to note
that so that we are realistic going
forward
that does not mean we should not
investigate every single allegation
that is credible we should obviously
i was the first person in america on
twitter at least to say
all legal votes should be counted all
illegal votes should not be counted
guess what i've been holding this since
tuesday it's hilarious how
the way our stupid politics works on
tuesday i say the outcome of the
election has not yet been determined and
everybody
goes crazy and then on friday i say the
outcome of the election has not been
determined and everybody on the other
side goes crazy
how about this the outcome of the
election is determined when it is
determined
but given the current vote counts the
trump campaign obviously has a serious
legal hill to climb we'll get to some of
these allegations in just a second again
allegations that voter fraud exists are
not sufficient to change the nature and
outcome of an election you have to prove
the size of the voter fraud you have to
demonstrate that it would have changed
the outcome of an election
that's just how the law works okay we'll
get to more of this in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that this holiday season the post
office is going to be super busy
you don't have time for that stamps.com
brings the post office and now ups
shipping directly to your computer you
can mail and ship anything from the
convenience of your home
or office many of us are going to be
apart for the holidays thanks to covet
well
now you can mail stuff from home or
office and you can do so cheaply and
efficiently
with stamps.com anything you can do at
the post office you can do with just a
few clicks plus
stamps.com will save you money with deep
discounts you can't even get at the post
office here at dailywire we've been
using stamps.com since 2017.
no more wasting our time stamps.com
brings the services of the us postal
service and ups directly to your
computer
stamps.com is a must-have for any
business whether you're a small office
sending out invoices an online seller
fulfilling orders during this
record-setting holiday season or even a
giant warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer you can print
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class mail anywhere you
want to send it once your mail is ready
just schedule a pickup or a drop off it
is indeed that simple
with stamps.com five cents off every
first class stamp up to 40
off priority mail up to 62 off ups
shipping rates and you get a special
deal right now with my promo code
shapiro you got a special offer it
includes a four-week trial
plus free postage and digital scale no
long-term commitments or contracts just
head on over to stamps.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage type in shapiro
that is stamps.com enter code shapiro
for that special deal
okay so let's get to some of the actual
allegations here
so yesterday ronna mcdaniel who's the
head of the rnc
she did a presser in which she announced
that there were 131 affidavits completed
in michigan
concerning voter fraud and voter
irregularities all of these every single
one
should be investigated so long as they
are credible as of
4 pm this afternoon 131 affidavits have
been completed just in michigan
with over 2 800 incident reports that
have been submitted
to us since election day two new
lawsuits were filed today by people who
were working who were working
in detroit and a whistleblower who has
gotten their information we have gotten
their information to the eastern
district court of michigan
okay so all of those should be
investigated and will be investigated it
is worth noting at this point that 131
allegations or or affidavits
in michigan is unlikely to change the
voting outcome
in michigan because the fact is that in
the presidential election
uh president trump ended up right now
he's down in the actual vote count by
about 150
000 votes 146 000 votes so it's going to
be difficult for him to overcome that
burden even with 131 affidavits now
listen
should our systems be cleaner absolutely
right our system should be run
like florida would it be great if there
were no voter fraud no voter regularity
absolutely but that is not the legal
burden the legal standard here is you
have to prove enough
i'm just telling you so we're realistic
about the future here guys this is not
mean
the system can't get better it doesn't
need to be better what it does mean is
if you are expecting the outcome of the
election to shift
based on voter fraud or voter
irregularity you have to look at the
actual hard numbers and the actual legal
standard because there is a process it
is going to go to court that is the way
that this works now there are cases
where voter glitches do change outcomes
for example daily wire ryan's veteran
reporting an incumbent republican in
michigan actually went from losing his
re-election race to winning it
after officials discovered a technical
glitch by which the results from seven
precincts had been counted twice
officials responded to the error by
urging voters to have confidence in the
system adam kochendurfer
republican of rochester hills went to
bed tuesday night believing with all
precincts reporting he had lost his seat
on a 21-member board of commissioners to
democratic challenger
melanie hartman by 104 votes but there
was a problem according to the oakland
county clerk lisa brown the total from
seven precincts in the city had been
reported twice so the final account
correctly moved coach endorfer
from a 104 vote loss to a 1127
vote victory okay right so these are
small numbers but those small numbers
matter in
an election in which they're only 40 000
total votes so you do see stuff like
this
right it is important to note that the
presence of voter fraud and voter
regularity
does not mean that entire huge election
suaves
decided by tens of thousands or hundreds
of thousands of votes are going to
switch this is a point made by the
georgia secretary of state yesterday
so he said yeah we're gonna find voter
fraud and yeah we're gonna find voter
irregularity but i'm he's a republican
secretary of state in georgia by the way
he's saying that is not going to likely
change
the the 12 000 vote margin in georgia
remember al gore couldn't even get via
recount in florida and be all of the
legal maneuvering he couldn't even
narrow
a 1 000 vote differential between him
and george w bush in 2000
okay meanwhile lindsey graham presented
an avid
in an affidavit from a pennsylvania mail
carrier
his name was richard hopkins he's a mail
carrier who claims he was instructed to
collect late ballots with the apparent
intent from postmaster robert weisenbach
to back date the votes
hopkins made the claim and he signed
affidavit under the penalty of perjury
although as i understand pennsylvania
law ballots must be postmarked by 8 pm
on election day november 3rd 2020 in
pennsylvania
postmaster rob weisenbach directed my
co-workers and i to pick up ballast
after election day and provide them to
him the affidavit reads in part adding
what i heard weisenbach
tell a supervisor at my office that
weisenbach was back dating the postmarks
on the ballots to make it appear as
though the ballots had been collected on
november 3rd 2020 despite them in fact
being collected on november 4th
and possibly later a u.s postal service
spokesperson told the outlet it was
aware of hopkins's claim
and has referred the matter to the us
postal inspection service and the office
of
the inspector general weisenbach to not
respond back to a request
for comment graham said in a statement
it is imperative that all credible
allegations of voting irregularities and
misconduct
be investigated he said the presidential
election remains close in multiple
states as chairman of the senate
judiciary committee all credible
allegations of voting irregularities and
misconduct
will be taken seriously i will not allow
credible allegations of voting
irregularities or misconduct
to be swept under the rug good it'll be
fully investigated right
the message of the show today all of
this stuff can
and should be fully investigated and
will be i think
and will be meanwhile in michigan
a third lawsuit has been filed over
michigan's vote count this one was filed
in wayne county circuit court alleging
problems with the counting process at
tcf center in detroit the filing relies
on the affidavits of four republican
poll challengers and a city of detroit
employee
who said she worked in the city's
election headquarters through september
a satellite clerk's office in october
and the tcf center the day after the
election is according to the detroit
news
besides the affidavits no actual
evidence of the alleged issues was
presented the allegations
range from restrictions on poll
challengers to late arriving batches of
absentee ballots to the encouragement of
early voters to cast their ballots for
democratic presidential candidate joe
biden
election officials said they allowed the
maximum number of poll watchers for both
democrats and republicans only
restricting access to additional poll
watchers because of
covet 19 concerns the suit seeks an
independent audit of the election a halt
to the certification of wayne county
votes
an order voiding the county's election
results and the initiation of a new
election
in wayne county there's also there's
already been judges who have turned this
down
and meanwhile there's a lot of questions
about pennsylvania now i think it is
important here to distinguish between
allegations of voter fraud and voter
regularity
and the changing of the rules that
happened in pennsylvania okay one
reality here is that the changing of the
rules all over the united states to
allow for
mail-in voting not on request right not
not absentee voting that you get you
request a mail-in ballot it comes to you
you then vote
but the vast sending of ballots to
people
because of covid or for any other reason
because supposedly was unsafe to vote in
person even though we literally had tens
of millions of people vote in person
and no massive outbreak due to it and
we've had evidence from earlier on there
was a there was an election in wisconsin
earlier this year
in which there were big lines to vote
and uh no no coveted outbreak
the changing of those rules is in fact a
problem
and it's a problem that needs to be
fixed the changing of the rules to not
allow pre-tabulation of the votes before
the election day
that is a problem and it undercuts faith
in the system
the the pennsylvania rules that
suggested that you might be able to
count a ballot after it arrived after
election day
without a postmark right that undercuts
people's faith
in the safety and security of the
election system
all of those things are systemic changes
that are dangerous
that is not quite the same as voter
fraud or voter irregularities so it's
important to tease out the various
issues
for sure and now all these issues
i believe are going to be teased out and
i think that we are seeing responsible
rhetoric from people like mike lee
from people like mitch mcconnell we'll
get to that in just one second because
while we are seeing responsible rhetoric
really i don't think it's irresponsible
for republican
senators to say the process is going to
play out we have faith in the process
why is that more irresponsible than
simply declaring the election is over
and if you refuse to repeat it you're a
bad person
which is the media's take on all this
here are some of the republicans
responding to all of this so mike lee
the senator from utah he put out a
statement his statement says
both candidates have every right to
exhaust every legal remedy at their
disposal under the law
voters on both sides of the political
aisle understandably expect and indeed
deserve
to have a high level of confidence in
the results of each election especially
in a close highly disputed presidential
election
the candidates are uniquely positioned
to decide whether to request recounts
verify the accuracy of data and
otherwise take steps to ensure that all
votes have been counted properly
and lawfully i look forward to working
with whichever candidate emerges as the
winner
at the end of this process okay and then
mitch mcconnell said yesterday he was
talking about listen the states haven't
certified yet so all of this talk about
how
if we refuse to just say president-elect
biden it's because he literally is not
president-elect biden
it's hilarious we've had fact checkers
who've been like white on rice
going after every supposed missed
statement by president trump for four
years
then the entire media declared that joe
biden is in fact the president's elect
fact check he is not the president-elect
okay he becomes the president-elect
when the process concludes and when the
electors vote for joe biden the electors
haven't even met yet here's mitch
mcconnell making that very obvious point
obviously no states have yet certified
their election results we have at least
one or two states that are already on
track
for a recount and i believe the
president may have
legal challenges underway in at least
five
states the core principle here
is not complicated in the united states
of america
all legal ballots must be counted
any illegal ballots must not be counted
why is this wildly controversial i'm
just wondering okay the reason it's
wildly controversial is because the
media have simply declared that the
election is over
and they want to move on with their
lives even though again the american
public have very serious questions
many of them about the irregularities
and the possibility of
people playing around with the election
so the new york times has an entire
article today about how evil republicans
are how terrible terrible republicans
are
declining to recognize biden's victory
mcconnell says trump is 100 entitled to
challenge it
okay well again the biden victory is
still preliminary considering not a
single state is certified it's election
result
this idea that we have to bully every
single republican into saying
that that biden is the president-elect
even though the process has not yet
concluded
concessions when you concede an election
it makes things easier for everybody
because everybody can then just move on
with the assumption
but until it's actually formally
appealed that is the assumption right i
mean that it's an assumption it is not
in fact
a legal outcome but the idea here is
that you're very bad and you're
undercutting the electoral integrity of
the united states if you don't
call for the assumption to be made
across the board
and so you end up with stuff like this
so yesterday kaylee mackinnaney
was doing a presser talking about voting
fraud and voting irregularities now here
is my general rule
politicians and political actors get to
speak i think that the obama
administration lied routinely
routinely i think that jay carney would
go out in those press conferences on
behalf of barack obama and he would lie
i think barack obama lied to the
american people regularly barack obama
lied that if you liked your plan you
could keep your plan barack obama lied
that the iranians were on the brink of
moderation if only we made concessions
to them barack obama lied about a vast
number of issues
but you know what you still got to
broadcast that because the american
people are entitled to more information
not less and you can always debunk it
later
right you cannot this is why they have
fact checkers supposedly but yesterday
on fox news fox news did something that
frankly i haven't seen a lot and it does
demonstrate the
level of the news media's arrogance when
it comes to not just fact checking
news sources but literally cutting them
off because they don't like what they
are saying
okay so kaylee mcinerney was on fox news
and neil kavoda who i generally like
just cuts her off
right she's doing a presser accusing
democrats and voting irregularities and
again it's either going to be evidence
or it's not going to be evidenced
and if it's not evidenced then people
are going to say that the kayleigh
mackinney wasn't telling the truth all
of that is fair
but to cut her off literally in the
middle of the presser so that the
american people cannot even see the
information
this is where we now stand our bettors
right our media bettors have decided
what you can see and what you can hear
and that is not appropriate
social media have been doing the same
thing social media have been bullied
into shutting down true stories kevin
roose
who has literally bullied facebook into
lowering engagement on conservative
pages it's insane
facebook's entire company is now being
run by some woke staffers
and a bunch of idiots at the new york
times who write op-eds and send nasty
tweets about ooh look
look look shapiro's page dan bongino's
page mark levin's page
people are paying attention to them
that's really bad you guys should
downgrade them
kevin roose put out a tweet suggesting
it was disinformation to point out that
an election result in michigan did shift
it did shift that's not disinformation
you just don't like the narrative
tough but the idea here is that social
media and media are our saviors because
you see they are wiser than you and they
are wiser than i am and therefore they
get to censor what you see and what you
hear now again i am happy to debunk any
claim that is false made by a republican
or democrat
you can do that but first you have to
listen to the claim here's kaylee
mcinerney being cut off by neil cavuto
yesterday
we want to protect the franchise of the
american people
we want an honest accurate lawful count
we want maximum sunlight we want maximum
transparency we want every legal vote to
be counted and we want every
illegal vote well i just think we have
to be very clear that she's charging uh
the other side is welcoming fraud and
welcoming illegal voting
unless she has more details to back that
up i can't in good countenance continue
showing you this
why i mean seriously couldn't you just
come on right after that and say
you know i don't think she provided any
evidence of those pretty outrageous
charges
couldn't he just come on i can't in good
countenance continue showing you this
who are you
i mean seriously like what are you god
i can't you can't see that information
you might agree with that information
you might be miserable misled you might
be misled
right yeah that that would be a problem
and there thus you cannot see the
information oh that that's great
i want my media ella censoring what i
can see what i can hear that is
definitely what i am looking for here
and that kind of stuff from fox news
that that even the fox news host last
night tucker was like you got
like our own network is be clowning
itself here okay that followed hard
on an outtake from sandra smith on fox
news uh acting exasperated
when other guests on fox news said oh
you know what we might want to wait for
the legal process to play itself out and
sandra smith didn't realize she was
still on camera and i was rather
skeptical of this claim
whoever is decided to be the president
remember
just because cnn says or even fox news
says that somebody's present doesn't
make them president
so i think everybody needs to know that
this was done properly
and legally what is happening like trace
we've called it
okay we called it and therefore it's
called right and once the media call it
it is the truth that is the way that
this works
i only have one problem with this which
is that i don't trust the members of our
media to make objective determinations
not only that i certainly do not trust
the members of our media to determine
what i can see and what i can hear so
that i can determine whether their
determinations are in fact correct or
not
we're going to get some more of this in
just a second because it is pretty wild
how the media have unmasked themselves
generally speaking the establishment
media
have unmasked themselves during during
this election we'll get to that in just
one second first as a parent i would do
anything anything to protect my kids i'm
sure you would too imagine you're a
parent
pacing around after your injured child
in a hospital room
a doctor begins asking you question
after question about how your kid got
hurt and you begin to realize they're
asking about your involvement in the
accident where were you when he fell
how do you actually fall and then you
slowly start to see that they think you
actually hurt your own child
wondering nbc news presents do no harm
it's a terrifying true story of a family
torn apart by the system that was
supposed to protect them
investigative reporter mike hickson
chronicles what happens to the bright
family when their three kids are ripped
away from them and the shocking moments
that came next with exclusive audio
captured as the events unfolded
do no harm takes you inside the most
harrowing moments of the brights family
fight to protect their children
subscribe to do no harm on apple podcast
join wonder plus in the laundry app to
listen
one week early and ad free i mean
honestly this is something that
seriously a lot of parents worry about i
worry about this
i worry about the fact that there are
authorities
who are out there you know on the state
and local level who are willing to
separate you
from your kids if they believe without
evidence that you've done something bad
to your
i mean this is scary stuff and
wondering's podcast about this do no
harm
is a must listen go check them out
subscribe to juno harm on apple podcast
and join wonder plus in the wondery app
to listen one week
early as well as ad free okay so
as we were talking about the
establishment media cannot be trusted
i'm going to show you more proof that
the establishment media cannot be
trusted
you simply should not listen to the
narratives that they are spewing at you
without checking it that is why we here
at daily wire are focused in on becoming
the replacement media we wish to help
you
replace the bad information and bad
narratives that you're getting from so
many pseudo-objective journalists
and replace that with something true
this is why you should head on over to
daily wire right now and get 25
off with code election and join the team
join the team you can keep up with us on
all of the unfolding twists and turns of
the election which affair
which is not technically over yet not
only that
we have big plans for the next four
years regardless of who the president
turns out to be because
again our goal is to replace the media
outlets that you used to trust and that
are no longer trustworthy that is why we
are launching into the cultural space
i am happy to announce that candace
owens new york times best-selling author
founder of the
founder of the blexit foundation will be
launching a brand new show with us early
next year in nashville
as well as writing content for us over
at dailywire.com we're also launching an
entertainment
entertainment channel so that you're not
giving your money to the cuties folks
over at netflix a new investigative
journalism
team we're building partnerships with
like-minded content creators like
prageru
we have an ambitious plan for next year
we're rolling it out we are the
replacement media that
is our job we are going to try and
replace the outlets that you shouldn't
be giving your money to and that you
shouldn't be trusting
the entire show library of prageru by
the way is available to dailywire.com
members by the end of the year and again
that's aside from all the wonderful
benefits
you already get you get the leftist
tears tumblers you get the the
all access live in which i answer your
questions
flex my uh rather puny muscles and uh
and sing to you again that is 25
off your daily wire membership with code
election when you sign up today because
if there's one thing 2020 has taught us
it's that anything
can happen you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so when i say that you cannot trust the
uh establishment media i really really
really mean it
right so we over the past few weeks we
have the specter of a cnn contributor
who had denied
on air that he was the anonymous author
from inside the trump administration
writing crap about trump
acknowledged that he was in fact that
person but he lied to anderson cooper on
air about it did cnn even suspend him
nope
and then today we find out that john
meacham
the presidential historian wrote the
speech that joe biden gave
on saturday night he's been writing
speeches for joe biden apparently all
along
and then he's been going on msnbc and
commenting on the speeches that he wrote
sources told the new york times
according to fox news that meacham had
been quote playing a larger role than
was previously known behind the scenes
both writing drafts of speeches and
offering edits on many of mr biden's big
addresses
including the one he gave at gettysburg
last month and his acceptance speech at
the dnc
biden campaign press secretary tj
ducklow told the times quote
president-elect joe biden wrote the
speech he delivered to the american
people on saturday night
but given the significance of the speech
he consulted a number of important and
diverse voices as part of his writing
process
as he often does meacham who publicly
endorsed biden back in march has long
been a go-to analyst
for msnbc the times reported that
according to a network source
measurement would no longer be a paid
contributor going forward but don't
worry he'll still be welcome as a guest
meacham did appear on msnbc following
biden's speech on saturday
he was asked by brian williams another
news anchor
who makes up stories about avoiding
gunfire in helicopters over a rock i
mean
okay i'm sorry the specter of brian
williams who's a falsifier of his own
stories
asking questions to john meacham who
wrote a speech for biden
about that same biden's speech neither
disclosing that meacham was actually the
author of the speech
that is p that's peak media i mean that
is peak establishment media stuff right
there
so brian williams asked quote i'm not
the historian that you are i don't have
the pulitzer that you do but do you
concur this is the way we are used to
hearing from our presidents
absolutely meacham answered why you know
it's pretty incredible
john meacham loved the speech that john
meacham wrote who could have known
well why that's there's a shocker that's
a that's a huge shocker
our media are thoroughly corrupt
thoroughly corrupt
jake tapper who again very often i think
jake tapper is the only person in the
media who will ask a tough question to
folks on the left
this was not a good example of this so
jake tapper tweeted out yesterday quote
i truly sympathize with those dealing
with losing it's not easy but at a
certain point one has to think not only
about what's best for the nation
peaceful transfer of power but how any
future employers might see your
character defined during adversity
okay that sounds an awful lot like that
sounds an awful lot like
if you don't act the way that i want you
to right now people might not hire you
in the future
so that sounds like so a few minutes
later he followed up
and he followed up that tweet and he
said
i mean i don't expect the ride or die
crew to listen to me but
so it says here on your resume that you
drove a sex offender to testify at four
seasons total landscaping north
of the tocconi palmyra bridge okay so
that is the reference to rudy giuliani
doing a a
much belly-hooded press conference
yesterday about voter fraud
but the the basic idea that you might
want to think about what your future
employers are going to think about you
and all this
yeah that that sort of subtle
implication there which is that if you
act the wrong way here guys
if you act the wrong way here people
might not hiring in the future
that is what has led to the backlash and
the backlash has taken a few forms one
the rise of alternative media
sources like ours and two the rise of a
huge number of americans
who are voting in ways that the media
simply cannot detect
because they don't want to be covered by
the media they don't want to talk to the
media they don't want the attention
because they understand what goes on in
these media outlets
these media outlets have become
thoroughly corrupted by their own bubble
they've decided that it's their way or
the highway there's actually a fantastic
piece over in new york magazine
about the the goings on over at the new
york times
and it does demonstrate full scale how
corrupt our media are
according to that article in new york
magazine
they're talking about tom cotton's
column you remember this back during the
election cycle tom cotton wrote a column
the senator from arkansas
about how the insurrection act might in
fact be justified to stop rioting and
looting
in america's major cities if local
authorities wouldn't do it and james
bennett the op-ed editor of the new york
times ended up losing his job for
printing that
after a bunch of staffers said they were
unsafe poor babies they were unsafe
because a sitting united states senator
wrote a column that 55
of americans by polling data agreed with
okay so here's new york magazine's
description
of what happened the conversation turned
into what more than one times employee
described to me as a food fight
during the melee opinion columnist
elizabeth bruning uploaded a pdf of john
rawls's treatise on public reason in an
attempt to elevate the discussion
what we're having is really a
philosophical conversation and it
concerns the unfinished business of
liberalism at bruning road
i think all human beings are born
philosophers that is that we have an
innate desire to understand what our
world means
what we owe to one another and how to
live good lives philosophy schmolosophy
wrote a researcher at the times whose
slack avatar was the logo for the
hamburger chain jack in the box
we're at a barricade's moment in our
history you decide which side are you on
by monday morning bennett was out so i
mean this is the way that it works over
there
this is the war the way that it works
over at the new york times according to
the new york magazine
in the weeks that followed one opinion
staffer told me it felt like no one at
the time got any work done at all
there were focus groups 38 of them in
counting and working groups and
innumerable conversations about what the
paper should be and look like and who it
was for
the masthead started holding black
people meetings as one black employee
put it to me
in which members of the mass had talked
one-on-one with employees of color to
sort out why they felt the times was an
unwelcoming place
in hashtag newsroom feedback there were
many days in which several people were
typing
the gears of institutional change were
slowly churning
okay this is the this is the best part
of the article okay they're talking
about how
the outraged new york times staff had
basically taken over the op-ed page
the section sometimes ran into the same
problems last month opinion published a
column by a chinese government official
arguing for the country's military
crackdown in hong kong
it was a virtual repeat of the cotton
situation the hashtag newsroom feedback
channel lit up briefly but the
conversation was muted
the china op-ed didn't hit home because
everyone is exhausted one times reporter
said
you can't be mad all the time everyone
agreed that broad reforms would have to
wait until
after november after the election that's
when the broad reforms were going to
kick in
and that's when presumably they would
start to be angry about the fact that
china just subjected hong kong to
absolute tyranny i think you should
trust these people
i think you absolutely should trust
these people or alternatively you should
definitely not trust these people and
you should go subscribe to daily wire it
sounds self-serving it also happens to
be the truth but
subscribe to blaze tv subscribe to dave
daley wire
go give a donation to the daily caller
news foundation like seriously
go get alternative sources media because
these people are simply not trustworthy
you know the other predictable effect of
all of this
is of course that shy trump effect that
the media were completely unable to
detect
and they can't believe it they don't
understand why there are so many
americans who simply didn't tell them
the truth and polls
i mean where did these tens of millions
of americans who supported trump come
from
i mean it was unthinkable that even a
single one of their friends could have
supported donald trump let alone
millions and millions of americans
so there were two possible ways out of
this ideological conundrum
way number one was you could do like
michelle obama and simply declare the
tens of millions of americans were
racist sexist bigot homophobes
who were ridden with hatred and simply
wanted to keep the status quo that is
way number one way number two
would be to actually be a little
introspective in the media and say to
yourself
okay we missed it in 2016. and then we
missed it again in 2020.
what did we do wrong what can we do
differently and maybe you might want to
hire
a person who voted for trump i don't
know you should think about it
considering that donald trump won 48 of
the vote and over 70 million votes
making him the second leading vote
getter
in presidential election election
history like donald trump
pardon par this is population growth
part of this is huge voter turnout
donald trump won more absolute votes
than barack obama did in either of his
elections
so that means there are tens of millions
of americans who are willing to pull the
lever for that guy
is there a single person who voted for
donald trump and will say so clearly
working for the new york times
seriously it's a real question is there
a single person
working a regular gig at cnn who voted
for donald trump
one i'm just i'm not asking for 10 i'm
not asking for 100 i'm asking for one
is there one person at msnbc is there
one person at abc news nbc news cbs who
will clearly say i voted for trump and
why
you can't find one weird weird and then
inside the bubble they're like
well you know we are the arbiters of the
truth and we will tell you that
elections are legitimate
we will call i can't imagine why there's
systemic distrust of the people who are
calling elections
i can't imagine why there's systemic
distrust of people who declare the
narratives
i can't imagine why the establishment
media are blowing themselves out
it's amazing the media are saying you
know it's really bad that trump is
undermining
election integrity okay you know who
undermined election integrity before
donald trump you know who did it
it was you jackasses for four years you
undermined the election integrity of
2016.
you undermine the election integrity of
2018 and now when you flip around you
say hey listen
our elections are perfectly clean why
should we listen to you at any point
here
seriously why how about we listen to
people who are consistent
who say that the process works i said
the process worked in 2016. i said the
process worked in 2018.
i said before this election the process
was going to work and the process is
going to work
and guess what there's a process and
it's going to play out but this idea
that we're supposed to simply
blind ourselves and listen to our
objective news media bettors
gfy man seriously
now the predictable result of all of
this is of course that
trump effect so really really
interesting article by a guy named eric
kaufman
he's a professor of politics at birkbeck
university of london
he says with the final ballots yet to be
counted with the next president still
unknown the polling post mortem is
underway
so much of the experience of watching
returns remarks frustrated msnbc anchor
chris hayes was anchored by the pulling
going into it it was a bad night for
pulling an enormous
pulling miss why did the pollsters get
it so wrong
posters typically receive low response
rates to calls that leads them to
undercount key demographics
to get around this they typically wait
for key categories like race education
or gender
if they get too few latinos or whites
without degrees they adjust their
numbers to match the actual electorate
but most attitudes very far more within
a group like university graduates than
between graduates and non-graduates
so even if you have the correct share of
graduates and non-graduates
you might be selecting the more liberal
minded among them for example in the
2019 american national election
study pilot survey education level
predicts less than one percent of the
variation
in whether a white person voted for
trump in 2016. by contrast
their feelings toward illegal
immigration on a zero to 100 thermometer
predicts over 30 percent
of the variation in other words when you
see pollsters say well you know we
properly sampled high school educated
white voters
it really matters whether those high
school educated white voters are
baristas in seattle
or whether they are farmers out in
eastern washington
it turns out that education level might
not be the greatest predictor
it turns out that there might be
complicating factors maybe you're over
sampling
non-college graduates who are the
baristas with the earring and two nose
rings
working at starbucks rather than the
rather than the guy who is working a
manufacturing shift over at the local
factory
unless posters wait for attitudes in
psychology which is tricky because
positions can be caused by candidate
support they miss much of the actions
according to eric kaufman again
professor of politics at university of
london
he says looking at this elections errors
i wonder if political correctness lies
at the heart of the problem
political correctness refers to the
policing of speech so that it conforms
to cultural taboos especially the ones
concerning race gender and sexuality
those who wield the taboos gain
rhetorical power encouraging them to
stretch the meaning of concepts such as
racism to encompass non-racist actions
such as voting for donald trump
in other words if you keep calling
people racist and you keep extending
those taboos people are going to treat
the taboos as taboos and then they will
not tell you what they are doing
across all racial groups 80 percent of
americans say political correctness is a
problem in our country
only the small progressive activist 8
percent of the us population thinks it's
not
in practice the burden of political
correctness arguably falls most heavily
on university-educated republican
supporters data from a recent cato
institute survey shows
88 percent of trump voting graduates
compared to just 44
of clinton supporting graduates agreed
that the political climate these days
prevents me from saying things i believe
because others might find them offensive
so he says 45 percent of republicans
with degrees compared to 23 percent of
democrats with degrees
said they feared their careers would be
at risk if their views became known
okay well that is going to have an
impact on that shy trump effect so where
are the shy trumpers they are not
the high school educated whites they are
college educated whites
particularly college-educated white
women they don't want to tell pollsters
what they are thinking
because they are afraid of the social
ostracization as well as people like
jake tapper saying well watch what
you're saying in this moment because
people not hiring might not hire you
how does this affect polling according
to frank lunds he told emily maylis
trump voters were over twice as likely
as biden voters by a margin of 19 to 9
to conceal their intended vote from
others i would expect this ratio to be
considerably
higher among university graduates which
would accordingly skew predictions the
most among graduates
posters claim to have overcome this
problem by comparing telephone and
online surveys and finding no difference
because online surveys are anonymous
they reason a shy trump effect should
reveal itself
and they find none but we know that
people who internalize social norms
conceal their views in online surveys in
other words
just because you're online doesn't mean
that you are going to answer honestly
these questions even though they are
somewhat anonymous
for example a recent survey of north
american academics
found that 23 percent of academics were
willing to state they would discriminate
against a trump voter for a job but the
actual share when using concealed
techniques called the list experiment
was 42
which by the way is i mean that's an
extraordinary number right that's 42
of academics saying they would
discriminate against a trump voter for a
job you think that's not going to have
an impact
there's also a problem of blowback among
elite republicans once has said that
feedback from trump supporting
respondents revealed considerable
resentment toward pollsters who are
perceived as part of a media
establishment out to misrepresent them
why would they possibly think that
considering that the pollsters keep
saying they are racist
this may explain why the polls didn't do
badly in predicting the white
non-graduate vote but failed
miserably among white graduates
according to a pewter survey on october
trump was leading biden by 21 points
with white non-graduates but trailing
him by 26 points among white graduates
likewise a political abc poll on october
11th found that trump leads by 26 points
among white voters without four-year
college degrees but biden holds a
31-point lead with white college
graduates but
the exit polls showed that trump ran
even among white college graduates
49-49 even had an edge among white
female graduates
50-49 so pre-election surveys were off
by a whopping 26 to 31 points
among white graduates by contrast among
whites without degrees the actual tilt
in the election was 64-35 a 29-point gap
and the polls basically
got that right that is a massive error
it's a massive error and what that
suggests is that republicans who are
more educated meaning they are more
likely to come into contact with
democrats who are telling them they're
racist sexist bigot homophobes
those are the ones who are being shy
about this
so what that means for the future is
that the more that democrats and the
media rely on this narrative the more
they refuse
to actually investigate their own biases
and their own hatred for people on the
other side of the aisle
the more they refuse to hire a single
trump voter to write on the pages of the
new york times ed page
the more people are going to internalize
the media's hatred for them and then
they are not going to tell the truth on
how they vote
and they're going to vote republican
more and more often this is the good
news from the 2020 election no matter
which way it goes
and there's a lot of heartache for a lot
of republicans who are looking at the
numbers the raw numbers from georgia
arizona nevada pennsylvania and they're
thinking to themselves that there's a
high likelihood that joe biden is
president-elect
or will be president-elect when the
process is finished okay here is the
good news the good news is the path
forward for the republicans is rosy
it is really bad for democrats democrats
have decided on a coalition
of aggrieved racial politics that is not
a winning coalition
in fact demographics are not destiny
right the argument of both the racist
alt-right
and the mainstream left is the
demographic's our destiny that a
coalition
of blacks hispanics gays asians
that that is going to be the new
minority majority and that is going to
swamp
the white vote in the united states and
that it's all about the demographics the
alt-right thinks the same thing by the
way which is why they want fewer people
who don't look like them
in the country right it's funny the
mainstream left in the alt-right agree
demographics are destiny then there are
the rest of us who think that people
ought to be treated as individuals
and you know what the evidence bears out
that when you treat people as
individuals they act as individuals
the new york times has an entire piece
today about how democrats missed trump's
appeal to latino voters
according to jennifer medina she says
after four years of draconian trump
immigration policies and divisive
messaging the biden campaign quoted
latino voters primarily by reminding
them that joe biden was not donald trump
that if they felt targeted in trump's
america a vote for biden would change
that
that argument resonated for many latinos
who became the second largest voting
group for the first time
this year but for others it was trump
who made them feel part of america not
targeted by it
teresa emilia emilio an accountant in
her 60s who immigrated from cuba
and attends an evangelical church in
miami said i've been in the country
since i was nine i've been through a lot
i'm an american
abortion is the litmus test jesus is my
savior trump is my president
democrats lost in florida in part
because of lackluster support among
latino voters
they did basically no better than they
do normally in texas in part because
hispanic voters in the rio grande valley
move decisively toward the gop
in arizona democrats will claim both of
the state senate seats for the first
time in decades fueled by young
progressive latino voters
for years many democrats have presumed
demography as destiny
believing that latinos would come to
vote for them with the same kind of
consistency black voters do
a growing latino population they hoped
would transform the political landscape
and give the party an edge in the
southwest
that dream ran into reality in this
election in which the results confirmed
what was evident from conversations with
hundreds of latino voters in dozens of
settings from the early days of the
democratic party
until the long ballot counting hours in
arizona over the last week the latino
vote is deeply divided and running as
not trump
was always going to be insufficient okay
this is the reality and it's very good
news for republicans so here's the good
news for republicans there are a lot of
voters
who voted for trump and they lied to
pollsters about it because they
understand political correctness and
it's dictat
there are a lot of latino voters who are
moving toward trump because they are not
going to be treated as a monolithic
voting bloc
in fact there are a lot of black voters
who move toward trump by exit polling
and outside shares of black males voted
for donald trump why
because he has as blunt and direct with
everyone as he is with everybody else
and that has some appeal to young black
males who've been pandered to by a
democratic party
that tells them nice lies and then makes
their lives worse
every day with policies in the inner
cities particularly
hey also we have been told that there is
no age shift happening
right we've been told that all of the
people who were 18 to 29 and went for
obama in 2008 and they are not shifting
right that they are going to remain blue
voters forever
and that we are going to get this
permanent shift toward the blue as those
people continue to age
only one problem is sean trendy at real
clear politics points out
in 2008 18 to 29 year olds went 66-32
for obama
today that cohort is 30 to 41 years old
that cohort went for biden
by seven by seven so either 42 to 45
year olds are really trumpy or
there's doings at transpiring in other
words people shift as they age
as they have families as they realize
that the progressive oddities and
stupidities of their youth
no longer make sense so if you're
looking to a future for the republican
party
that future for the republican party is
quite bright and it is worth noting that
because
well i know a lot of people are
pessimistic right now
the fight is only beginning as i said
yesterday it's time to push it's time to
push
donald trump has wedged open a door with
many latino voters with some black
voters he alienated a lot of suburban
women those women voted for george w
bush twice and mitt romney in 2012.
a lot of those suburban women will come
back hey the fact is what we are
watching in real time
is the democratic party alienate so many
voters that they have they've alienated
themselves
into a minority in the country i truly
believe this and it's going to manifest
itself in the house over the next couple
of years
it's going to manifest itself in the
senate and i think it's going to
manifest itself in presidential races
if the democratic party decides to
double down on the poisonous 2012
campaign of barack obama which suggested
that instead of campaigning
as to americans as individuals you have
to campaign to americans
as groups i think it's really going to
go badly for democrats in the coming
years as americans decide you know what
i like being treated as an individual
and not as a member of a group and i
don't like being called a racist and i'm
gonna vote however i damn well please
and i also don't trust the media that
tell me i'm a racist if i don't vote
like all of our media bettors say that i
should vote okay meanwhile some actual
good news
pfizer announced yesterday that there's
a coveted 19th vaccine that is strongly
effective in early data
according to stat news pfizer and
partner bioentec said monday their
vaccine against coven 19 was strongly
effective exceeding expectations with
results that are likely to be met with
cautious excitement and relief in the
face of the global pandemic the stock
market
rocketed through the roof yesterday on
the news the vaccine is the first tested
in the united states to generate large
stage data
the company said an early analysis of
the results showed that individuals who
received two injections of the vaccine
three weeks apart
experienced more than 90 percent fewer
cases of symptomatic covenant 19 than
those who received a placebo for months
researchers have cautioned that a
vaccine might only be 60 to 70 effective
this is way
way way more effective than previously
supposed
william gruber pfizer senior president
of vaccine clinical research and
development told stat quote i've been in
vaccine development for 35 years
i've seen some really good things this
is extraordinary so this really bodes
well for us being able to get a handle
on the epidemic
and get us out of this situation the
pfizer ceo uh he came out yesterday and
he said
this is truly an amazing thing he said
this is a great day for humanity
here was the ceo of pfizer
it is a great day for science it is a
great
day for humanity when you realize that
your vaccine has a 90 effectiveness
that's overwhelming you understand
that the hopes of billions of people and
millions and
businesses and hundreds of governments
that were
felt on our shoulders now we can
incredibly threat them i think we can
see light at the end of the time okay
that is
dr albert borla who is the ceo of pfizer
so big pharma is good again
remember that time when big pharma was
evil big pharma is actually good there's
a lot of speculation that this
announcement was held until after the
election
that lacks evidence the only evidence
that that is the case is that apparently
pfizer and bioentech had decided in late
october that they were
going to drop a 32 case interim analysis
at that time the companies decided to
stop having their lab confirmed cases of
coven 19
in the study instead leaving samples in
storage the fda was aware of the
decision
discussions between the agency and
companies concluded testing began
this past wednesday when the samples
were tested there were 94 cases of covet
in the trial
this means that the statistical strength
of the result is far stronger than was
initially expected it also means that if
fizer had held to the original plan
the data would have been available in
october as albert borla had initially
predicted now that is not enough
evidence that this thing was held for
political purposes in fact
pfizer said the reason that we didn't
actually take public money when we were
developing the vaccine is we didn't want
this thing
to become political here's the pfizer
ceo saying listen we weren't working
with the election as a timeline here
for us the election day was always an
artificial date we were not working with
the election as a timeline
we were working i released a letter
if you remember meg to our employees
some time ago
saying that the only pressure we feel it
is the pressure of the billions of
people that are hoping on our vaccine
and we are going to follow the speed of
science so
science spoke and uh i was predicting
that this will happen
at the end of october it happened a week
later okay well
naturally um the media immediately
decided that it was time to say that
they said that trump had nothing to do
with it
so this this part is hilarious so the
pfizer head said that we weren't part of
warp speed
what pfizer's head meant by we weren't
part of warp speed is we did not take
initial money
right according to dr jansen who is uh
one of the
heads of pfizer she said she said we
were never part of warp speed we have
never taken any money from the us
government or from anyone
and well as it turns out pfizer is
indeed part of operation warpseed which
is trump's initiative to develop a
vaccine
because the government has declared that
on the back end if you develop the
vaccine that the government is going to
buy billions
of dollars worth of doses from pfizer so
they were in fact part of the
the warp speed operation they just were
not taking money up front
on monday a spokesperson for pfizer
clarified the company as part of
operation warp speed
as a supplier of a potential coronavirus
vaccine
okay and then hilariously enough the the
entire media
ran with the narrative that they weren't
part of warp speed so presumably trump
had nothing to do with the development
of the vaccine
the reality is the government were not
pledging to buy billions of dollars
worth of doses
then pfizer wouldn't be sinking hundreds
of millions of dollars presumably
into the development of the vaccine in
the first place
now democrats are sort of conflicted
over how to treat the news of the
vaccine
on the one hand you have chuck schumer
who's saying we need to combat vaccine
hesitancy he was the senate minority
leader yesterday
we democrats will do everything we can
to make sure this vaccine or any vaccine
is distributed quickly fairly equitably
and the challenge is now one of scale
and one of delivery
congress should fund a national
vaccination program
and the administration whether it's the
trump administration or the biden
administration
must do everything to reach minority and
underserved communities
combat vaccine hesitancy and ensure that
the vaccines are free
to everyone so number one that's already
been done right the vaccines are going
to be provided to the american public
also
when chuck schumer says it's time to
combat vaccine hesitancy maybe he should
call up the governor of new york he was
the governor of new york andrew cuomo
yesterday
saying that he's very angry that the
vaccine was developed while president
trump is president because now he
doesn't trust the vaccine which because
this is captain science over here
captain science makes shipped the old
people back into nursing homes with
kovid
he what an excellent governor he's been
right he wrote an entire book about what
an excellent governor
he has been while uh killing every old
person in new york with covet apparently
here was
here he was undercutting the efficacy of
a vaccine
the good news is uh the pfizer tests
look good and we'll have a vaccine
shortly the bad news is
that it's about two months before joe
biden
takes over and that means this
administration is going to be
implementing a vaccine
plan i've been talking to governors
across the nation about that
how can we shape the trump
administration vaccine plan to fix it
or stop it uh before it does damage
before it does unbelievable so he's
undercutting the efficacy
of the vaccine because again you need
people to trust the vaccine in order to
take it
absolutely unbelievable by the way in
other good news the fda has now granted
emergency authorization of a coven-19
treatment made by the american
pharmaceutical company eli lilly it was
given to chris christie when he was
infected with covid
that authorization only applies to
people newly infected with the virus the
treatment is approved for people 12
and older the treatment which is called
bam lan of the mibe
not kidding bam lan of himab should be
administered as soon as possible after a
positive test and within 10 days of
developing symptoms dr daniel
scovronski chief scientific officer of
eli eli lilly says it's a great day for
science and medicine
sort of a feat of what is possible so we
are reaching better therapeutics we are
coming close up
on a vaccine a lot of that is due to the
trump administration and its
mobilization
on all of this so naturally the media
have declared that trump is responsible
for hundreds of thousands of deaths
without giving him
any credit for any of this the science
the science
that dominates the left is truly
excellent science you know you know
what's going to cure this probably
probably if joe biden just has put on a
mask then all of this will be cured
and that's what joe biden said yesterday
joe biden he finally unveiled his
coveted plan yesterday just gonna note
this final mode here
joe biden who's declared himself
president-elect along with the networks
he uh he laid out his coveted plan it
turns out his coveted plan is
a task force yeah a task force
assemble the power rangers guys we need
to have a government task force
when i think of efficiency and
effectiveness when i think of how to
solve a problem
i think of a task force so he assembled
a task force that also includes
dr ezekiel emanuel who once famously
wrote a piece for the atlantic about why
everybody should accept death at 75
which uh if he actually took that
seriously would mean that he should
completely ignore covet since it is
disproportionately killing people
above the age of 75 in any case joe
biden laid out his plan
and guess what his plan was guys guess
what his plan was you ready his plan was
put on a mask boom boom pandemic over
joe biden dropping the hammer on kovid
by telling you to put on a mask
huge huge news here was joe biden we
could save tens of thousands of lives if
everyone would just wear a mask
for the next few months not democrat or
republican lives american lives
you know maybe would save the life of a
person who
stocks the shelf at your local grocery
store maybe it saves the life of a
member
of your place of worship maybe it saves
the lives of one of your children's
teachers
maybe it saves your life so please i
implore you
wear a mask and so i mean now that joe
biden has said it pandemic over gang
and then if you had did you have
questions about that do you have any
questions about joe biden's plan
uh i have some bad news for you he's not
answering questions so i'm glad that
covet has been cured by this this old
here here's joe biden kieran covey by
avoiding all questions catch you later
guys
i say masks you say what and then i
leave here's your bite i'm just leaving
thank you
pandemic solved guys pandemic solved i'm
so glad that uh the american public
decided that this person
was definitely gonna care coveted
excellent excellent excellent stuff
okay one final note last note just gonna
note here ben rhodes yesterday
now the the biden the incoming biden
administration they suppose will happen
ben rhodes uh he uh he came out
yesterday and he said the biden team
is already having calls with foreign
leaders here is a failed novelist
who became the progenitor of the iran
deal which he then admitted to the
american public he lied to the american
public about so he's
ben rhodes is just a bag of garbage he's
a bag of flaming garbage
left on somebody's doorstep as a
halloween prank he is just the worst so
here is ben rhodes
saying guess what members of the
incoming biden administration are
talking with foreign leaders already
the center of political gravity in this
country and the world is shifting to joe
biden
foreign leaders are already having phone
calls with joe biden talking about the
agenda they're going to pursue january
20th
if that reality hasn't sunk in yet for
some people in the white house it will
sink in
when they have to leave on january 20th
okay so i'm old enough to remember that
time that they tried to prosecute mike
flynn
for a logan act violation as the
incoming national security adviser for
having a conversation with the russians
so i guess logan act violation's all
around now let's start prosecuting
members of the biden administration i
think we need a full-scale investigation
i mean they're not they're not elected
yet and they're having foreign policy
conversations already
i was fully informed that that was very
bad that mike flynn did that even though
we had to read out of the conversations
just shows you the utter utter
dishonesty of the media the utter
dishonesty of the democrats they didn't
care two craps about mike flynn talking
to the russians
but you know what we got we we're
supposed to pretend along with them and
if we pretend
if we clap loudly enough tinker bell
will live alrighty so here is my bottom
line to all of this
stop paying attention to members of the
mainstream establishment media go get a
subscription to daily wire or blaze tv
or anywhere else that will provide you
actual information that is not biased to
the left all right we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boren
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavel wydowsky our
associate producers are nick sheehan and
rebecca doyle
the show is edited by adam scievent
audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by niko geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
journal's whale that trump will not
concede fraud turns up in swing states
and aoc threatens to leave politics
check it out on the michael knowles show